my first journey with G fuel I sought
them out because I already used their
product we struck a deal and then I
renegotiated to get less money from them
and get more G Fuel and then I decided I
want even lesser lesser lesser money to
get even more G fuel all right let's put
this in the
fridge yeah use our promo code in the in
the
description come on
[Music]
oh god I've lost my
mind ladies and gentlemen we just
learned that this is not the final
episode of season 1 and Roxy has to
maneuver her entire life schedule next
week so we can film it I'm going to try
don't be like Coy he always puts me in
this position for the final
episodes I you did okay this is totally
my fault first off
I'm going to let everyone know the 180
that just happened leave a like people
that'd be awesome hey also subscribe and
click that notification Bell to get
notified when our reaction is up for
episode something or another prepper I
think you edited these and I think you
did a great job full length Reaction
watch long where you single with your
own copy of hasell that is for our super
sexy rejects how you do patreon p the
Wonder just looks at me when I'm doing
the intro I could just see her looking
and it just makes me so uncomfortable
like
I don't like when people look at me I
don't like eye contact all right eye
contact is going to ruin my life I feel
like people can see how puny I really am
on the inside when people look at me in
the
eyes and uh yeah let's watch the show
let's have a good
time I'm actually excited to know more
about vaggie me too we don't know
anything about vaggie
vagy I don't know no saggy vaggy vaggie
I have a light jacket flat jacket and
rain jacket does it rain in Heaven
Charlie you're only going to heaven for
a few hours yeah why you dodging Heaven
it's our last chance to convince Heaven
a soul can be redeemed yeah I wish I
could come sweetie sweetie but I have
that thing what thing the thing with God
I'm such a bad liar what is going on
veggy what did she do to get to hell I
need you there with me fine why do these
last two episodes Sly make it so clear
that they're partners look at this maybe
they got feedback yeah for people like
us it's who happened to me and the
answer is everyone twice Val had me
working 16 hours straight on a whim no
jeez what the is with that wall what
up oh my God she's back [__] Cherry bom
CH Cherry not since the pilot you've
been texting me a depressing [__] all
day figured we could tear [__] up like
old times here hold this oh my God oh my
God nope give me that I love seeing
Jerry I'm she played hot potato with it
I need to pass out oh you can sleep when
you're double Dead come on what you
really need is a recharge a responsible
night on the town that is a great idea
buzz kill so nice to meet one of Angel's
Friends he never brings anyone around
wonder why yeah me too anyway she's so
innocent hi everyone Angel and his
friend are taking you all out for a
night of fun and relaxation wait I am
only here for and O never mind let's
go sure they have the best time tonight
anyway the portal to heaven should be
opening right about I mean the best time
tonight would probably be some really
bad things yeah was not good
phrasing if it isn't my arch nemesis
have you come
to I'm going out with I Angel and I got
to drag your sorry asses along you and
me are going out like for fun I I didn't
think this would ever
happen what do I wear don't [__]
touch me a mon head I didn't really like
him when he first showed up in the show
but ever since he started checking in
this hotel it's been so funny isn't that
amazing yep interesting design what is
this Heaven wow it's generic Heaven chai
I'm not seeing you on my list um my dad
got me to this meeting so maybe try
Lucifer
yeah yikes cuz I think you might be a
little lost no uh we're we're here for a
meeting oh no St Peter we can take it
from here it is St Peter okay I'm Sarah
the high seraphim of Heaven hi I'm Emily
the other seraphim though you can call
me m they're going to get along great
yeah there's got to be a Twist to it
it's got to be more cool design on them
though
[Music]
my this feels like trolls
does oh my god this is my
jam how did a crocodile get to heaven
that crocodile ate no one never hey hey
don't judge maybe it's a vegetarian
Croc
[Music]
wow her voice is killer
too this is all a
lie it's a lie oh no what's behind the
curtain I don't like this holy [__]
balls am I seeing what I think I'm
seeing what is is she doing here how did
she even get up here who cares like the
mean girls in school waiting for the
extermination what was the seraphim's
one rule no one but the Exorcist can
know about the exterminations I know
fine that's right you got to Kill The
Exorcist but they know how to kill the
Exorcist well you failed to control the
Demon's unrest and now Lucifer is
involved setting up an audience for his
misguided daughter I never would have
agreed to your yearly activities I
thought it would bring trouble to our
doorstep keeping Heaven safe was my only
reason for allowing it okay okay I want
you to do whatever you need to do to
keep this problem from getting any worse
are we clear yeah Adam is such a toad
this Utopia is full of lies I don't like
it they sprinkles made of rainbows Em's
going to take me to a zoo where all the
animals are actually soft you coming
she's tempted by heaven but hug a koala
for me OMG can you imagine an actual
koala see you later she really hates it
here I feel bad Charlie deserves to be
hey there vesaur Charlie will be back
soon you need to get out I'm not looking
for the blonde babe I'm looking for you
oh here we go maybe cuz you left the
band you tried for a solo career or I
guess it's more of a duet I don't know
what you're talking about what I
wouldn't recognize one of my top girls
just cuz you're out of
uniform you were on the front lines I
wouldn't forget a bad [__] like you she
was an angel warrior best thing ever
vagi actually it's pronounced
vaggi no everyone's knows be call you
vaggie oh my God I was not expecting
this run
now filth like you has no place in
heaven oh my God wait I was always
wondering why she was nicer than
everybody else she was originally in
heaven think someone as worthless as you
landed Lilith's little hottie grats on
that I guess wow a now I love their love
I wonder what your [__] would think if
she found out you are actually one of us
that's why she didn't want to go to
heaven either oh my God it's all making
sense Greg yeah I get it now you're
going to help me shut this kindergarten
snowflake [__] down for good you
pompus [__] I guess I'll just tell
Little Miss butterflies and rainbows
that she's been someone who's killed
thousands of her people oh she doesn't
know her true background no she's found
her at the dump store I thought like
maybe she told her the truth about it
already no this is why she said you
don't want to go to heaven she's not
telling her why we are gathered here
today to determine whether or not a soul
in hell can be redeemed into the
Heavenly Realm by means of this hasbin
hotel Webster's Dictionary defines the
worst way objection lame and unoriginal
I'm with uh I'm with on this one no
further dictionary references
please we have a patron angel dust oh
yeah the poor demon he's totally worth
being redeemed what do you think it
takes to get into heaven
um well uh come on Adam is everything
okay Adam give me aing minute okay just
got to ride out his thoughts chat GB it
act selfless don't steal Stick it to the
Man well I bet is doing all of those
things right now then let's see it bro
oh no oh partying a [__] your honors may
I present exhibit a who isn't this place
the best I'll admit consent is a good
name for a sex club Nifty what are you
doing I'm sweeping nothing hellish about
consent look how hicky it is in here
that's because we're at a club yeah I
thought the hotel looked
different I need a drink after today you
know Val he's in this waterboarding [__]
now I don't know it's a kink oh manad he
already ruined your whole day don't let
him ruin your night too here take one of
these and you won't be worried about
nothing No Angel D you want to up all
your progress be my guest I just thought
you were better than that a I don't know
it's been a long night and I don't need
to go too wild oh good thing Heaven's
watching come on you deserve a little
RNR in some THC or maybe PCP with
DMT let's see where the night takes us
huh there are a lot of abbreviations for
the drugs I bought you a
shot because I bought everyone another
shot another I alcohol he likes her oh
no let's do
it oh no what more do you need to see
the porn star chose a KN of debauchery
that's not a soul worthy of being in
heaven it's not that bad it's not like
killing people what do you think I I I
have to go to the bathroom what faggie
can you hold it faggie hold your vaggie
angel will make good decisions come on
we have to keep watching yeah I don't
know yeah let's give him a chance very
well the court will allow it [__]
yes what but Adam's been saying the f
word the entire time it's like Adam
lives by different rules it's annoying
next one's
on Nifty
[__] like what's up with Nifty bro
you're supposed to be relaxing not
playing Nanny she ain't used to this
scene I just don't want her to end up in
the G like I used to hey he's doing the
right thing whatever nerd just catch up
when you're done God this is like our
Dynamic when we're out I'm like angel
dust I'm like who that other girl I'm
Nifty you're Cherry Bomb ni why you
being such a
mess Chom like like let me be
responsible for one night oh my
God you want to play with the
kitties
yeah I see the club has
a so I was thinking
maybe he is silly as sex with
me I'm sorry why would we have SE
because I'm having with
everyone just constantly tries to
justify like no it's not it's not just
for
you you're gorgeous do you need a job
how many can you o i can let's get the
[__] out of here like at once or in a
row okay y drink or I'll [__] kill
you
no Nifty
Nifty holy [__] Angel D you didn't get
enough today funny who's this chikita no
fresh meat no I just want to
taste weird but there's a kink for that
I'm sure oh my God [__] off B excuse me
I said [__] off whoa you forget who
you're talking to I own you [__] in the
studio just like like oural say but out
here I get to do what I want God damn
right enjoy the rest of your night
because I'm going to enjoy making you
pay for it tomorrow gu's such an [__]
I hate him so
much what the [__] for my
collection nifty's Terror ericon he did
everything on your checklist he was
selfless he stopped Nifty from stealing
and he stuck it to that Moth Man Man
true then why isn't he here then wait
none of you know what gets someone into
heaven
ooh we know when they pass Divine
judgment it is our job to ensure these
souls are safe fascinating but she was
right Sarah she showed us the soul can
improve he saw the light
Sarah nipple
chills look I got goose iose is who's to
say yeah and under what
[Music]
qualifications of course and that's why
you shouldn't just be condemned forever
to
hell
no oh my God this might be my favorite
[Music]
song this could be a Broadway musical
yeah page Escape infernal Blaze
[Music]
yes and there's a lot that you don't
know
SAR yeah Petty
indeed shouldn't be
only can't wait to come down and
exterminate
you you go down there and kill
those the B
deal decision oh my God it's all coming
[Music]
out yes girl
yeah a little
bit
morals that's what the [__] I've
been
[Music]
yes this is
great [__] to kill
them yes yes I was told not to trust in
Angels by her oh no oh no oh no Greg oh
no they're going to OU her did you ever
think your little girlfriend might be a
liar why hide the fact that you're an
angel just like
[Music]
us
oh oh no d different feeling nipple
chills I think those are called
[Laughter]
tears this court finds that there is no
evidence souls in hell can be redeemed
what you better save the date cuz we're
coming to your hotel first what a Croc
of [__] extermination of human Souls
demon or not there is no reason to be
doing this yep they were Uprising Emily
it is my position as the head seraphim
to protect our people at all costs I
heard other can't just commit acts of
genocide yeah Heaven needs us Emily and
we can't doubt ourselves a worry about
the fates of demons when we have our own
souls to protect if you start to
question you could end up like Lucifer
Fallen all Lucifer did was question the
man but so now we know that Lucifer
isn't the only fallen angel I'm sorry so
vaggie's one yeah so that multiple
people can go that direction but nobody
can go this direction
yeah come on Greg that's not fair I
cannot get over this
why why what why is it that short what I
can't get over is
why you haven't bought yourself a real
reject shirt yet I can't get over that
either you know what guys it has been a
miraculous year for us but I still see
there's so many citizens of the reject
Nation who have not got themselves a
t-shirt they haven't gotten one yeah
surprised so many good options there's
so many good options and they feel good
do they feel
comfortable the quality of the shirt is
super comfy I like to hear yeah I love
this paid her $30 more dollars to say
that no you didn't I didn't she got suck
I like the ones that are really like
thick and boxy I don't like we don't
have that I know that's what I'm saying
that's why I like this one it's like
molds to me yes it's a nice quality
t-shirt it's a molding t-shirt and you
know what I mean I do know what you mean
I love the shirt no well thank you we
got a whole bunch of other shirts too
and it's a great way to support the
channel my personal favorite way you can
support the channel you look good good
while doing it and on top of that too we
uh for vast majority of that we are
creatively involved with them ourselves
didn't you design this one I came up
with it and got an artist to help out
yes and they did a great job it's a
smart one it's it's the biggest seller I
get why I mean it's a brilliant shirt
you and I both brilliant shirt yeah my
chance and Andrew showed up to film with
John in the back out said he was weing I
was like everyone's just picking this
shirt today yeah and uh yeah so thank
you guys also yourself from G feel while
you're at it because that shit's amazing
I love this episode a lot yeah this is a
really good one great music tonight
great music tonight indeed uh I love
religious talks I do I found religion
very fascinating even though I'm not
religious at all I grew up religious and
you know especially with Heaven and Hell
being the discussion they're posing all
these questions that I just love to see
brought to life and I I love how it
there's there's a hint there's such an
irony to it where you are seeing Heaven
portrayed initially upon First
Impressions how it is uh generally
portrayed when you're kind of growing up
and seeing images of Heaven just the
pearly white Gates and St Peter there
and everything is Grand and beautiful
and nothing goes bad here but you see
there's all this like political
hierarchy mess uh with a lot of unjust
happening to people in Acts of genocide
and I I think the way they have found a
gray like this whole conversation was
about the gray and and then you see that
heaven does not really adhere to a gray
yet there's such a gray with the with
the souls of hell and who and what
qualifies someone to be condemned
forever and like they're talking about
angel dust and committing these acts of
debauchery but like what what qualifies
you to be in Hell forever like what
really does you know unless you're like
a mass murderer or some [__] you know
like I don't really understand is it
about how you treat yourself or is it
about how you treat others because we
see Angel treat everybody else well yeah
but himself yeah uh you know he's
poisoning himself yeah while doing right
by uh by everybody else other than his
boss who does Wrong by him you know like
the boss it's very clearly he should be
in hell but there are these people in
the middle uh and it yeah it's like the
embodiment of the Pink Floyd song right
like do you think you could tell and I
don't know if some of the when they
asked it was interesting that they decid
to make it when they asked the Angels
you guys don't even know the
qualifications for getting somebody in
here and then Adam names three things
and while angel dust did hit those three
things those aren't like the three
things right I mean they were just kind
of random things that he spewed out but
what are the things what does make
somebody good what does make somebody
evil and are the most of are most people
just somewhere in
between I think that's the whole point
of it being the the gray conversation
that most people are probably just in
between and it's it's it's an unfair s
the whole concept of hell just does what
they haven't introduced yet is God right
they haven't and I feel they haven't
even I don't think they' even said the
word God have they even said the word
God no the only reference that I thought
we were getting is when she when Charlie
kept being like I want to talk to the
person in charge I want to talk to the
person at the top but it seems in this
world they keep bringing Adam up as the
first being here the first in heaven and
it was like first Soul the first soul in
heaven and so I thought that when we
were going above Adam we were going to
go to God but in Dad we went to the
mother daughter Duo what what's the
seraphim yeah yeah yeah yeah cuz the the
question that was that has lingered in
my brain for so long especially when I
did grow up Catholic and then was
finding myself going you know what maybe
for me was had a lot to do with the very
concept of what hell is you know uh like
oh God is this all loving father
unconditionally loves you but if you
make some mistakes while you're on Earth
you're going to be bad vanish forever
unless at the last second you apologize
yeah it's like everyone has their
opinions of it never made sense to me
like but if he's his like
unconditionally loving father why would
he just banish you forever like the
fiery bits of hell this doesn't make
sense to me that I feel like that
there's it contradicts itself and and I
love that the show is actually they're
full heartedly addressing um a topic
that's why I loved it so much is a it's
a big debate is what they done here and
and I I think um there's such a there's
such a there's something kind of like
beautiful about putting it in a
childlike animation style because it's
questioning and challenging
traditionalism and to put it in a kind
of traditionalist nostalgic type of
Animation
flare just kind of further drives home
that point and uh this episode did it to
such Exquisite quality which is again
great song that I think Advance like
it's so easy to pay attention to the
songs the songs are so about the
narrative yeah the lyrics are amazing
the tunes are amazing the voices are
amazing they all kind of just make you
think I can't help but while I'm
watching this though there's a little
voice in the back of my head that
continues to say where is Lilith yeah of
course I just the whole time I'm like is
she here is she there where is Lilith
it's true I have no idea where Lilith is
where is Lilith and and the alist Lilith
connection I feel like has to be there
somehow we should um I mean yeah they've
been gone the same amount of time yeah
yeah and alistair's on somebody's leash
we know that Lilith is not with Lucifer
right now and now we do know that there
is a way to get from Heaven to Hell and
Hell To Heaven wouldn't it be cool to
like disappear for a few years I
sometimes have that fantasy just
disappear for a few years and then come
back and people like where you been
you're all like mysterious about it and
no one really knows would that be cool I
don't feel that way you don't feel that
way you never think that way sometimes I
just want to like abandon
everything I I hope you don't feel that
way
often oh it's a great feel when I think
about it and I just get lost there I'm
really sorry that's tough what sounds
really tough is it not it's joyous just
leave everyone and
[Music]
everything yes come on
right is that rock and roll baby let us
know in the comments below this she's
want to like hide get away from it
all I don't I don't what oh man you're
crazy man oh you're
crazy I got a lot of people who rely on
me I couldn't leave them oh God but
imagine like not having any
responsibilities I like having
responsibilities oh what we two
different
people totally
well I think we know that from the start
of this video because I can't even look
at you without you being upset with me
so hey that's just that's just all
people well we are clearly examples of
the gray and we're on two different ends
of the gray yeah I still accept Roxy for
being the weirdo she
is and yes it is me and uh I'm glad that
she understands what normaly should look
like so and she's found it in a friend
like Greg so you think you
tell see freak Heaven from
Hell blue skies from pain no I have no
idea what you're doing what I could
learn this when I'm living in the woods
though remember remember all just bring
Wish You Were Here Pink
F learn all these words I'm chopping
down my my wood my
lumber get a big beard some people in
the comments were upset with me but I
can't help it you read the comments I
always read every comment you know that
I love hearing what they have to say and
I I respond to a lot of them you guys
have been amazingly complimentary but uh
some people were upset about me
continuing to compare this to Harley
Quinn yeah what the hell but the Harley
Quinn guys I cut down more of it than
you realize really the Harley Quinn
poison ivy Dynamic uh is super similar
to the Charlie vaggy Dynamic sometimes I
am really curious what Charlie's going
to do now that she knows that vagy was a
angel what do it matter I mean I think
what it matter I think what what what
would she was M she was
killing Charlie's
people yeah but she reformed and she
lied to her but she reformed she's still
lying how are you reformed if you're
still lying I mean yes yes but there's a
gray to it Roxy right right I think they
will eventually be okay but right now
did you not get vibes with uh Charlie
and the Young
Angel as they were singing together I
was like whoa I didn't get vibes of V
vaggy so you know I I for all for all I
know your gar is off I know Harley and
her already banging you know yeah um
maybe yeah well they just share a b as
BFF oh I think there's a gray there you
know like she reformed and she still she
still went against what how the Angels
thought so she found herself a for a way
of Reformation as well remember that
song where she's like what am I if I'm
not here for you I think her entire
identity is that Charlie found her yeah
she's being there for Charlie but that's
not
real yeah but you know I I think also
the other thing that people are
forgetting Charlie's also an
angel right she princess of hell though
she's princess of hell but she's also
she's she is still I don't know what to
qualify
is she an angel if you're the kid of an
Angel she be like a a Nephilim or
something I forget what the word is but
she would be something she mix yeah
she's mixed she is she's she's mixed she
because because her father's an angel
yeah but I don't know if you are
considered an angel if you is by your
blood yeah I mean by other other forms
of mediums that I've seen that that
usually yeah if you are just every other
half angel interesting though because in
this in the world every Angel is the
like if your if your dad I'll use a
different example because he's
dead if your freak if your cousin is it
in hell you talking about my dead cousin
yeah whatever for okay well go to me
just because if my mom's in heaven it
doesn't make me an angel if I do bad
things then I go that's a soul though in
heaven doesn't make you an angel are you
saying that every soul here in heaven is
portrayed like an angel cuz I don't
think that's what they're saying I feel
like there's like civilians
would be Spectators in the colum
watching this judg go I get what you're
saying not everybody in Heaven's an
angel no she was she was before the
Council of angels there um yeah yeah
yeah I thought those were like higher
Angels no no I think it's in the same
way of how like in Hell not everyone
there is like a Overlord or some type of
demonic not everyone's Alistair you know
something else I am yo yeah dude I'm
here to help you understand help me help
you exactly and I apologize for my
behavior
today well apologize facing this way cuz
if you apologize looking at me I know we
have a problem I apologize Roxy that's
okay should we get out of here should we
should we call each other on the phone
talk next to
text and the video
Ro okay
[Laughter]
later a deal
Chamberlain
Adelia we are going to change the lyrics
of De is gone oh no to and I don't
actually know what this is about oh good
I've definitely heard the song before
it's by Johnny Cash yes and we're going
to discover together but instead of deia
we going to change to aiaia see what we
did here we go okay
Adelia oh
Adelia Adelia oh my my life if I hadn't
shot
Adelia yes I'd have had her for my wife
oh no a is gone one more round a is gone
he's shot more than once I went up to
Memphis or Nebraska wherever you're from
definitely Nebraska and I met a deia
there found her in her parlor and tied
her to her chair excellent a deal is
gone for real one more round a is gone
what is happening in this song how how
many times does he shoot her she was low
down and trifling and she was cold and
mean kind of evil make me want to grab
my Submachine what adilia is gone he's
going to hit you with the chopper adilia
run Adia is
gone first time I shot her I shot her in
the side
hard to watch her suffer but with a
second shot she died about your evil
twin Adia is gone one more round is gone
pour one out but jayer oh
jayer jiler I can't sleep you get your
come upins now cuz all around my bedside
I heard the patter of adelia's feet
haunting him in the afterlife Adelia is
gone one more round round a deali is
gone a throw one back so if your woman's
devilish you can let her run or you can
bring her down and do oh my God good
deal Go Johnny Go Go Johnny a is gone
one more round a is
gone is gone one more round a is gone
now at your funeral I'm going to sing
that in honor of you and confuse the
hell out of your entire family I've
never heard this song before and I think
this is perfect I always thought it was
about a horse until I read the lyrics it
could be like a bad horse yeah yeah yeah
it's like a devilish is devilish brood
mayare or something like that but you
know clearly this was inspired by like
the the opposite traits of you anyway I
hope you're doing well
and I hope you recover from all the
gunshot yes we love you stay safe out
[Music]
there